a lot of a lot of mentors and the bosses
and some good and some bad it's a good
question if I think about for a second I
think the one that you know I like
slogans and easy to remember and you
live a little bit by and head interview
a few weeks ago somebody asked the same
question and I think one that is is very
true and you know not corny and not just
out of a book but Cubby's keep the end
in mind or start with the end in mind I
think works you know almost universally
and especially in senior management of
large complicated companies i think is
is perfect advice that is it it seems so
simple but it's not again a big
companies with a lot of variables and a
lot of trade-offs that have to be made
but you really have to decide where do I
have to get and again back to bring it
back to the Cadillac story back in 98
was okay what do we have to be where do
we want to be who do we want to be until
you answer those questions you can't
work yourself back into any kind of a
product plan or marketing plan or
financial plan that that's really the
end is the start of all those strategies
and the second one was from one of my
bosses specific bosses and it was
urgency action empowerment so you got to
work every day like might be your last
so there's you know the trade-off of
keeping the end in mind which is always
long term but operating every day with a
high sense of urgency you know
actionable make decisions you know don't
drum them around drum around revalued we
reevaluate so and then empowerment and
you can't do everything so one of the
talks we're gonna hear this afternoon is
focus a lot about that you really have
to empower people got have good people
Collins talked about it and the right
people on the right bus and that and
then give them the right tools and I let
him go you if you think you can do it
all you're
grossly mistaken and I'm going to learn
the hard way so those are a couple that
I found a live by that it work